hello turns video playing in the rain
maker let's see what he does that gives
me the center again I think we had
something similar yeah we had something
like that right he went with 93 and now
he goes for an open center surprising
yeah so take or not to take and usually
keeping a little bit more pieces on the
board makes sense if you have more space
so let's keep more pieces on the board
prepare but should be 627 here wow just
like that okay maybe I I'm sure it's
just stuck mumbling if i should have
inserted a 6 or North's always a
difficult guy ok so here i got a good i
would like to play the night to d5 but
first of all isn't Bishop takes age
success could be something
you
hmm a six would be nice if you had to
take it but there is this irritating
Bishop takes h6 move I don't know if
it's good actually but I cast will go
for that it's kind of interesting or
make you can yeah I saw that but I
wasn't really sure what this means here
this pollution I'm a little bit weak on
the dark squares but that also applies
for white yeah if I can push away the
night 95 c 3 is pretty pretty awkward so
we'll see what happens and it's not
going to check made me here quickly I
think at least I think maybe h4 h5 that
could be interesting just push the pawns
you
something that night a4 and push the
night away Knight to c3 looks extremely
pretty but i'm a bit unsure about the
effectiveness ok he also has to worry
somewhat of me just taking stuff a two
for example ok so he directly goes for
something here ok I have to push this
night somewhere else and here what's the
deal b7 is hanging going to f4 is
something that could be quite annoying
maybe just Queen to e5 let them take on
b7 and I'll take a two now rupee five
looks like a self-penned some that isn't
very me that much Wow whatever weird
position it's equal material I don't
like my fashionable King position that's
really cause for concern long-term can
easily happen that I win one or two
pawns and everything looks nice and then
he gets some attack on my king
yeah stuff like that and what to do if i
take the night I mean the Queen at least
somewhat away from the action I probably
I should take this first this also
covers you see that the c7 porn ok so he
wants to keep the night potentially 496
I see him I see SC SC SC for probably
should have avoided that by taking it
first ok anyway there is Queenie to
maybe but it's got Queen f4 could be
good reply
Wow we should 27 and then just like take
it I mean no taking this role man and
men covering at the uncovering c6 took a
long time for that move
maybe I can play d4 and if the Queen
moves I know to be seven or something
active than F for myself that could be
an idea i currently have everything
protected so I just try if I can get get
something going myself if it takes it
how do I recapture that's interesting
Queen takes is with the tempo that makes
it kind of attractive rook takes when
men can try g43 just drops back okay um
so Queenie to is a trade anything
clearly there's some clear argument
against I don't see it so that's this is
the Queen trade and then I had
materialized yes time morning something
that I should have thought of I can take
here can I cannot cover this in any way
c6 is bad I don't like the coordination
of my pieces now this is the main
problem shoot I don't like it
check
check okay that looks somewhat save at
least how does his store my pond
it doesn't check check check check check
white resigns Oh tough game tough game
you very very hard to evaluate what was
going on there objectively yeah so this
time he decided to take on d5 and then
this move yeah i don't know i went to be
six maybe seven less actually making
more sense to have night at five to
default but okay it's definitely
playable check yeah this is a quite
complicated now of course I can play
something normal Queenie seven or so but
I was kind of intrigued by this idea
maybe it's just not a good idea and yeah
this the computer and the engine also
points out this way of doing it and legs
wide yeah probably this is true I mean
here he only has a slight weakness on c2
to worry about and he has weakened my
kingdom yeah it's probably better than
this and here no idea what's going on
engine wants to play Queen to e7 I went
f5 okay i can probably analyze this in
quite some detail yeah the computer
thinks I'm
I'm clearly better which I thought was
possible because the night is somewhat
stranded but it is such a complicated
position in turn my my am king is a
little bit off yeah I computer likes
what I'm doing here gives me cleared so
I didn't play it all that badly and now
but now it wants to just go before yeah
this is a Texas a night huh no I was
really more about my king safety him and
no oh no I can't win with route takes f3
wow yeah that's a setup was very strong
the kind of move if you see it you see
how strong it is check check and is all
check and winning everything in with
checks okay that would have been a
winner but ok i played this and this was
yeah this was giving away my advantage I
wanted to be safe the computer wants to
go for this damn it makes sense where's
the Queen going and they have Queen III
and things like that the engine thinks
this is the best move now and this is
almost like giving it up yeah okay let
this wasn't doing doing all that much
yeah so this this King age 6 it took it
and now he should play nice to be three
it seems and why this fine check this is
again quite ok for mac and somehow here
I am Bishop f3s losing knight c6 esperia
attacking the default porn and winning
the default phone I will get age 5 and
we have a draw
I guess now my porn is just yeah just
promoting check yeah a good fight I
think interesting game to watch sure
hope okay thanks for watching